.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Jesse: KAMALA HARRIS TO THE
RESCUE.
WELL, KAMALA IS FINALLY TAKING
HER BIG TRIP TO EUROPE NEXT
WEEK.
POLAND AND ROMANIA TO BE EXACT.
AND TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE
AND NATO THE VICE PRESIDENT WILL
MEET WITH LEADERS OF BOTH
COUNTRIES TO DISCUSSING RUSSIA'S
INVASION.
NO SURPRISE SHE WAS CHOSEN TO GO
SINCE SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
FOREIGN POLICY WIZ.
>> YOU KNOW, JOE IS -- TALKING
WITH JOE ABOUT A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES, AND YOU KNOW, JOE, I
THINK HE SAID IT QUITE WELL, HE
SAYS, YOU KNOW, FOREIGN POLICY
MIGHT SOUND COMPLICATED BUT
REALLY IT'S RELATIONSHIPS.
JUST THINK ABOUT IT AS
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND SO WE KNOW THIS IN OUR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONSHIP.
>> Jesse: HERE NOW DOUGLAS
MURRAY, AUTHOR OF REQUESTED MAD
MADNESS OF CROWDS.
"JUST ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS.
>> STRAIGHTFORWARD THAT WHOLE
THING.
>> Jesse: NOT THAT COMPLICATED.
>> IF PEOPLE COULD POINT ME ONE
THING THAT KAMALA HARRIS HAS
SOLD THERE MIGHT BE ONE REASON
FOR EUROPEANS TO HAVE HOPE.
JESSE, YOU KNOW VERY WELL,
NOBODY CAN POINT TO ONE THING
SHE HAS SOLVED.
SHE HAS GIVEN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER CRISIS, 2 MILLION I WILL
MEAL MIGRANTS CAME ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IN THE LAST
YEAR.
THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE CRISES
SHE HAS FAILED TO SOLVE.
LOOK AT ANYTHING SHE HAS BEEN
GIVEN IN HER STRANGE PORTFOLIO
NOT SOLVED ANY OF IT SO WHO DO
YOU SEND TO SOLVE THE MOST
INTRACTABLE PROBLEM OF THE
MOMENT AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
WORLD WAR III BUT KAMALA HARRIS?
>> Jesse: MAYBE IS HE SENDING
HER BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WANT TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
MAYBE HE THINKS THAT YOU KNOW WE
DRAG THIS THING OUT, YOU LET
RUSSIA FIGHT THIS THING FOREVER,
HE DOESN'T WANT A QUICK FIX.
THE WEST WAY TO DO THAT SEND
KAMALA.
>> HE IS EXPECTING THAT KAMALA
WILL SAY SO MANY BENILE THINGS
SUCH A LONG TIME THAT THE
CONFLICT WILL BE OVER BY THEN.
REMEMBER SHE WENT TO MUNICH THE
OTHER DAY AND TOLD THE EUROPEANS
THAT THEY THEY HAD TO REMEMBER
THEY WERE IN EUROPE AND THAT
THERE WAS A WAR AND THAT,
THEREFORE, THIS MEANT THERE WAS
A WAR IN EUROPE.
>> Jesse: WAR IS BAD.
>> WAR IS BAD AND KAMALA TOLD
THEM THAT AND SHE TOLD THEM
WHERE THEY WERE AND THAT WAR WAS
BAD.
SO, BUT IF WE CAN EXPECT MORE OF
THAT FROM HER, THEN, YES, IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT JOE BIDEN SIMPLY
SEND HER TO JUST KEEP THIS
RUNNING UNTIL THE END.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK BECAUSE
THE LAST TIME SHE WENT THERE THE
VERY DAY SHE LEFT PUTIN INVADED?
SO DO YOU THINK HE IS GOING TO
TWEAK THE UNITED STATES AGAIN ON
THE WEEK SHE SHOWS UP?
HE HAS GOT MAYBE A TRICK UP HIS
SLEEVE.
>> OBVIOUSLY ALL JUST ABOUT
RELATIONSHIPS WITH JESSE.
>> Jesse: IT IS ABOUT
RELATIONSHIPS.
>> ALL THAT SHE NEEDS TO DO IS
TO GET A BETTER RELATIONSHIP
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
CAN GET IN THERE, CHARM THE
KREMLIN AND MAYBE THEY STOP.
I MEAN ON A SERIOUS NOTE.
>> Jesse: REALLY WE SHOULD NOT
BE JOKING ABOUT THIS BUT IT IS
THE LAST PERSON THAT I WOULD BE
SENDING.
>> I SPOKE TO UKRAINIAN LEADER
THEY SAID HOW DEVASTATED THEY
ARE THAT JOE BIDEN HAS DONE SO
LITTLE FOR THEM.
AND THIS EVEN -- EVEN MORE THAN
LITTLE, HE SENDS HIS VICE
PRESIDENT TO SOLVE IT.
>> Jesse: HE HAS TO SEND KAMALA
HE IS IN DELAWARE.